i'm gabriel i'm a support engineer at
cardo uh so i'm part of the support team
which we are the ones that deal with
clients uh deal with users and actually
support internally um we help out with
the platform we develop for the platform
it's literally support all around we go
from very high technical uh server um
you know improvements to going into our
ui and it's a really full stack so front
end back end and when you're a cardo
user you get contact with our team so we
can go as deep as you want or just
learning how to use builder overall so
it's literally everything
and you can just contact us if you have
any issues or if you want to figure out
how you want to use cardo in some way we
can help you out with that so again full
stack team so you're not just you can
contact us and ask us all the type of
questions you want
uh so for today's workshop we're going
to be analyzing user review scoring data
for air movie listings in los angeles
and we're using cardo for this so we're
going to go over
a different kind of analysis as we go
all across this data set and for these
specific slides you can come after and
we can email you them as you can see
there's two links there the early and b
data set that we're going to be using
today and plus this whole example is
documented in our website so you can go
step by step if you want to recreate it
later because i will be going a little
bit just because of you know to show the
full ability of cardo but you can
recreate it yourself and the data sets
there everything's there for you
so let's get started um so and
very quickly uh about what approach
we're going to take for this we are
going to be using h3 for this so for
some people that don't know h3 h3s are
hexagons geoms that are basically a nice
way to get um in uh like
in data analysis on like points that are
overlapping over each other within a
specific area so they're like uh
basically like quad keys if you
understand quad keys uh but we're gonna
be using h3 in these examples uh and
we'll see because airbnb listing data is
really all over the place so right on
top of each other about that to be there
so we're going to use h3 to help us
understand this data
and then specifically we're going to be
using our analytics toolbox for this so
besides just providing a ui we actually
provide
analysis functions that are easily able
you to create h3 gms quad keys all these
integrated into your data and uh
so enough of me talking about this and
let's get started
uh so when you create a card account
this is the first thing you see this is
the home screen uh you see all your
recent maps you see what's happening in
the platform
and then on the on the left you get the
home screen uh maps data explorer data
observatory connections applications and
settings so to start we're just going to
go to our data explorer
our data explorer is where all your data
is going to be housed so this includes
uh in every single cardo account we have
a cardo data warehouse this is a cloud
data service that we provide for free
for every single account
uh if you go in inside of here you see
that you can have your data in here it's
being shared and then you have demo data
which is if you've seen our examples
like these all the data would be in here
so we you have it for you automatically
and then the other thing we have is
actually a bigquery connection and this
is actually from an external cloud
service provider so you can easily
get a cloud service provider plugged in
right into cardo and be able to look
inside look inside the table
and look inside all the data sets within
which specifically we're going to be
using this cardo academy and this
project and these data sets in here
but how how do you create a connection
so it's as easy as going into we're
going to go to on the left side our
connections tab clicking connections
and this is where all our connections
for cloud data warehouse are held so
right here we have our bigquery
connection and create a connection is
easy as clicking this button new
connection we have the five cloud data
providers we have available right now
bigquery data bricks postgres redshift
snowflake
today we're going to do a bigquery one
so we're going to click bigquery
and we have two options a service
account or assigning google so for a
service account for all of you that
don't know it's a easy
credential json that is available for
bigquery so you can
generate this json credentials and
uh connect your bigquery project that
way or you can use the google sign-in
for that bigquery project so we're gonna
use the sign in
and then right away we're going to be
using my cardio account that's connected
to my bigger connection i'm going to
name it which i'm going to name it
test connection
and then deciding what project that all
my query uh that i'm going to be using
cardo is going to be um added to so i'm
going to put this project right here and
then
just put connect
and as easy as that i made a connection
to my bigquery data service
and so to be able to see what's in this
uh what's in my project for bigquery i
just go back to my data explorer because
remember this is where all my data is
held and where i can look at it it's
right here my test connection i drop
down and i see all my project in here
that's connected to it so as easy as
that we just had a data connection you
can do this for redchip all the
providers that we saw
uh besides just seeing the seeing the
data we can actually import data into
those connections themselves
so if you go here into our import button
you can import through your local file
or through a url
and we also provide auto guessing auto
guessing is that when you import data we
actually are able to get the column
types and and guess like if you have a
date time column you can make it into a
date time instead of a string so we're
we try to get as much information from
the data as possible and make the schema
for it
so for this example we're going to be
using a url right here and then we're
going to go back to our slides and go to
that
airbnb dataset right here copy it
go back to the workspace and just copy
and paste it into here and just put
continue
so right here we're going to name this
data set we're going to call it airbnb
listings and then when you click here
you actually see all of your connections
here's our test connection here's the
workshop connection we're going to use
for this example and our cardo data
warehouse so let's use the workshop
connection
and right here we're going to put it
into the same project that we are going
to be using
so we go here
we go we have our listings here and then
we're going to say in this folder put in
this data set that i took from a url we
put save here and you get a summary of
what you want to do and we put import
and as this imports you can just
minimize this right now and you can see
that this is working it's getting
imported up here you can continue to use
cardo while you import stuff so it's as
easy as that and we're actually
importing this into a bigquery project
not within a cardo data warehouse but in
your connection when you make it
and so when you open this up it's been
imported correctly and you were able to
see the airbnb list airbnb listing data
set right here
and so if you go to your bigquery
project you're able to see the same
exact data set we just provide you a
nice ui to be able to look at it
so this is a data preview of this table
you can do this for any of the per any
data set that you got imported into your
connections so first up we get a map
a very very simple map just to get a
general idea of the data set we're going
to be dealing with so this is los
angeles and these are the all the
airbnbs
you get the number of rows within this
table and you get the table size as well
and then in data preview you actually
get the rows and you can see the
autocaption coming into here you can see
if the right column type was added to
your row or you know maybe turn off auto
guessing off if you know you don't see
it done correctly
but you can see here we correctly put
all these s numbers which they are and
then we have a geom column right here
which correctly identified
so let's
create a map
so
for
this example we're going to be using the
exact same data set just named a little
different but it's exactly the same one
and creating it creating a map is as
simple as clicking on this top right
button create a map
and this opens up to our cardo builder
the cardo builder
oh
my
browser just crashed
sorry about that i will
one second
[Music]
uh let me just connect really quickly
sorry about that
um
and will i talk uh while i get this
setup of cole
can you help and explain a little bit
about carter while i
yeah so carter basically uh
take data
we're able to take your data enrichment
our data we've got over ten thousand
data sets
that you can now take more data and
a lot of companies are coming to us um
like a logistics company right now in
terms of prices so they're coming to us
how they can save time
you know during their trip and how
they're able to uh
because of the shortages with uh drivers
as well or they're able to cut out a
certain route to just have one truck um
yeah sorry about that
mozilla on this time
um so again we're we're in the set uh
let's create a map simple as create a
map
click this button and it leads us to our
cardo builder
which
it's
mozilla is not cooperating right now
uh
you know what let's just use brave
yeah as well
one second uh it seems mozilla is just
crashing on me for something uh firefox
is crashing on me for some reason
i don't know why
um
um but as cole was saying um
we try to be the the spatial um
the spatial toolbox for a lot of our
customers this includes building a ui
where you can easily create maps but
also on a deeper level where you're able
to
create like back end a lot of functions
for back end work
to create
like models spatial models for this
wait a second
let's go
put this over here
there we go
put this back
let's try this
okay
let's create this map again
the internet is going out for me
one second can cole can while i look
into this can you come up here and just
talk about it a bit more
thank you
sorry about this everyone
yeah so right now we are the
only cloud native uh geospatial platform
out there so basically uh carter comes
and sits on top of
the warehouse
um
actually so actually when we do this we
actually prepared a video of this demo
so we can show that as i debug it and
then midway through i can just go in and
start you know like continuing it with
it and then we can explain as we go
through really quickly so we'll do that
as a as a fix for now um
yeah we'll do that for now
gm so for this we're going to use our
cup
we imported it let's meet this one right
here we click on it and
okay
so
we're right back where we started
we imported the data set right now uh we
clicked it we went to the preview of it
and we're showing the favorite preview
and
get this part
and then right here
we're creating our map
uh so
the map gets generated
very quickly you can see that our data
set is within the map uh it's easy as
that you displayed it right away and you
can hover through and see what's in each
individual point
and you can zoom in it's a working map
and to be honest you as is it already is
a working map you can post this anywhere
uh but the reason why we want to
actually make this into an h3 geom is
because as we zoom in you see how these
points are right on top of each other
but we don't get a lot of cases into
this so for example if they have like
pricing averages or you know they have
different pricing around these points um
we don't really we can't really see it
that well
because there could be like a low price
airbnb listing in one place and a very
high one we want to get a general idea
of the area around this board
so for this part we're this is why we're
going to create h3g on the campus
we go around we see the pricing of each
one of them location volume
so for this we're going to go to our add
sources this is where you can create all
your source information from from it and
then you can
import your tables or your tilesets
whatever you want within your data
connection you
other club connection but to create
h3-gm we actually are going to run a
query we're actually going to do a sql
query from this we're going to do our
custom query sql and again pick the
right connection that you want to do
this way within the data sets
we're picking
up connection for this
and then type your inquiry right here
and then add source so this takes us to
our sql editor so again you can write
sql like you would do in bigquery but
you can do it within cardo and you can
actually import data into the map using
that
so we're going back to our
slides and then taking this sql right
here we're going to break this sql down
a bit in case you know some people off
the bat will know this is a pretty dense
equivalent uh but the key for this one
is this contribution this is a
specialized uh sql function that within
cardo we created to easily create h3
genomes so we go back to our sequencer
we put full screen so you can display
the whole thing
and then we're going to be running this
filter
as you can see here the sequel just like
they created checks if
the queries are run correctly it got run
correctly in the time about it
so we're breaking down the sql of it so
this is the table we're importing in
uh we're importing from and then we're
saying hey for every single one of the
airbnb listings we're using this
function here and find an h3id
for this table
so
um
and we're saying the
zoom level of this as well so then we're
making this into this table h3 airbnb
table um the thing to keep in mind with
this part is that since we're finding
for every single point of airbnb finding
an h3id
we're going to get duplicates right
because then multiple points are going
to be in an h3id so that's not very
useful to us
because then genomes are going to be
right on top of each other so that's
what we're actually doing in h3 airbnb
and in aggregate this is this part is
about the aggregate of them so we're
saying
take this duplicate h3d we're doing a
group by to get the unique hdid but then
we're getting the averages of the
pricing of the oval rating the value
versus price rating platelets rating and
location here and then we're removing
every
h3id that is less than three pointed in
because that's not really relevant to
our analysis that's really something to
look for
so as you can see here we get an overall
rating
and we're rounding it out so that's the
second part of this and then we're
actually adding an extra column here too
because we want to get some information
about this h3 geo we're going to say how
many points are within that geo right
because we care about that if maybe one
point at one h2 geom has like five
airbnb listings and one has 200
right that's a very large distinction
between the two
and then finally now that we have this
aggregate you actually need to get
genomes right where you've only been
talking about ids so this last part is
this function right here which again
it's part of our cardo analytics toolbox
we're taking those h3ids and then we're
actually converting them into genomes so
again like our atoms toolbox is not just
part of the ui but it's part of the
cardinal infrastructure we try to help
out as much as we can
and so from this part we run it and as
quickly as that
we have our h3 gym right in our map as
you can see here
and as we
float around we see the average pricing
of each one of them here
and so now let's get some more
information about these h3 geos
uh so
and let's organize a bit this a little
bit more because as you can see here we
have our layers
uh
and we're gonna rename them to just make
it a little bit friendlier so as quickly
as that is layered you can just rename
them to organize your layers so you
don't
have to really like to get jumbled on
which layers you want to use so you use
airbn listings which is
these points right here and then
the b1 which is our h3 genome we're
going to call it h3
and then let's move the airbag distance
right above you can just click drag and
drop right above the issues
as we saw here and let's remove them for
now so just focus on styling these h3
so we click on that button which is
style options and as you can see is
there is we want to focus on price for
this for this first
uh map
so we see that the pricing and the
averages of them so you click on fail
color
as you can see all the different
variations of pricing and we put color
and we put
color based on so for this we can pick a
column within your table to base the
color on to show the variations of them
so again because we're using pricing
pricing for this
right there and as quickly as that you
can see the variations of pricing across
this data set but what does they
actually mean so we actually have a
legend on the bottom right that we just
click and you can see the variations
between them you can see that the yellow
one is the most expensive of the arabic
new listings well these are ones are not
so much
uh with this in mind though uh we want
to like better style it and stylize this
because usually red means a little bit
more of and then yellow means less up so
then you click on the palette we're
going to add a little more steps to them
so it includes more variation between
them and then change the palette of them
as quickly as that
and so you can see the red ones now are
the most expensive area listings and the
legend automatically changes for that
use case
and let's remove the stroke for now just
to make it a little bit cleaner
there you go yeah that's
one thing to keep in mind while we did
this is that
um not all these german colors we we are
not really seeing
the variation between the two as we've
mentioned before so these three these
two genomes
have the same color but there might be
representative of different listings
right so how do we capture that because
we know that each one of these are
representative of a lot of listings or
very little listings so let's take a
little bit further
and i'll actually display this within
the map so people know about these
variations between these two data sets
and we're going to be using height for
this so we toggle height
and then we've made our jails into a 3d
geo map
as you can see here
and then to actually see this a little
bit better we go to map view you go to
3d view here you can see all the gems in
a 3d view now as quickly as that but as
you can see they're all the same height
so that's not really useful to us uh
right now so again similar to fill color
you go to more options you go to height
based
and then we're gonna
we're gonna choose the column that we
chose before which is total listings
which is the total listings within that
h3gr
so we click on that and you can see now
the height
the higher the deal the more listings
that they're all getting them
but they're still you can't really see
the variation like you can see a bit of
them but you don't see that much so you
can actually uh configure this by the
height
the height is what's the maximum a lot
of height within those genomes
so if we increase the height you can see
those variations a lot more as you see
here
and then we can
left click to go scroll around this 3d
image to better see the los angeles area
and it's a good reason we did that
because as you can see these are the
same colors but this has not that many
listings in it well this one has a lot
so we're capturing this uh dismissing
part of this data set and very easily
for someone to see as quickly as that
you're able to make a 3d map using h3
and again here with the left system so
we can see like there's way more density
within these pockets than we would
otherwise be
okay so that takes care of our first
analysis uh let's rename it as quickly
as that you can go to the top of carter
builder and we're renaming the map right
now everybody pricing
analysis right there
uh so
let's take it a little bit further
though let's you know this is one of our
maps so we're going to duplicate this
map it's easy as three dots up there
duplicate map
and then it'll start up another cargo
builder
and with exactly the same thing as
before our two sources are up here our
layers are up here
uh and just the name is different we
just say copy of and the name up top but
everything else should be exactly the
same we left exactly where we left off
and then we're going to actually focus
on location rating now instead of
pricing so we're removing the 3d because
this is another new analysis we're
chained we're removing the height
and then we're also removing the fill
color because remember we
pick this for pricing so now we're going
to configure it for location reading so
location reading is how great have
people rated this airbnb list
so
as we look around it kind of changed a
bit you can see that there is some like
pattern near the coast as everyone knows
like everyone wants to be near the beach
so there's some variation between that
but there's some that are not so much
but
there is some there is some uh small
announcements from this
um
but with this in mind we want to know
maybe how is location rating affected by
rating right because it's maybe it's not
all location that we base this on um but
it might be other factors that are part
of that rating overall rating because it
might be a location but
that's we don't see that all the time
though that this is happening
so
in this
so we're going to be using a model
so
this is our first one so we're going to
be using an advanced simple model on
this data set so we're going to be using
specifically graphical video regression
uh we wrote a whole blog post about this
one it's basically able to show
influences between points that are near
each other
um
but again this is a very overview of
this model i don't i don't want to go
into it very much but definitely check
out the blog post we break it down as
much as we can and again the slides will
be available to everyone
and specifically we're going to
integrate this model with this sql query
here so exactly what we did before we
have a sql query that you can be config
and made so you can easily be able to do
it our cardone analytics toolbox we use
this function we're basically calling
this table here
and we're saying
hey
what
how is overall rating affect these
specific uh columns value versus price
rating playlist rating location rating
and then we're defining the h3 variance
right here
as easy as that you can run your model
as you see here cleanliness rating and i
think the crucial part of this analysis
we're doing right now is just the
location reading and we're going to
compare the overall rating to this
so we're going to copy this suite sql
and then go back to our power builder
and then from here we're going to add
source from
we're going to go again back to our
custom query sql back to checking make
sure we're in the right connection where
our data is clicking on it
type join
sql back to the sql editor
full screen just to make sure we're
getting the correct sql in
putting it in
checking that our sql works up there and
then just running it
and right there you see the data
connection right there and as simple as
that we have our model run
as you can see here
so it should be right on top of the
current h3 geos that we have because
it's layer c up there
so we're just going to rename this just
so we don't mix up these layers as easy
as that
g w
h3gs
so let's
let's look into this data set a bit more
so we go to three dots here we actually
can see the data instead of just
displaying it and we can see what we
actually created from this model so we
see that h3id is here but we also see
the relationship between each of these
columns in the overall reading so the
higher the relation
the more closely that they're they're
connected together so maybe in an area
that has a very high overall rating
maybe it's because it's location-based
instead of cleanliness and other places
more cleanliness so
each of these columns represent that
relationship and for all the data
scientists out there like here is the
actual like uh you can configure it so
it maybe it's more accurate or less
accurate depending on that so in that
column
so
with this in mind again we're focusing
on location rating this is what we want
to analyze so we go to the same palette
style it and we're going to say location
rating based on its rating
we're going to set the steps again
and we're going to pick the palette as
we did before
so
to break it down if the red ones they're
they're more related to location
so if we zoom in
you can see
[Music]
using the legend which is in the top one
right here
this has way more relationship to the to
the ones that have negative they have no
relationship at all to locations of it
i don't know
uh but we still have a problem right now
uh we have two h3 genomes right on top
of each other right that's not very
helpful in our analysis because we have
this model and we have the current http
uh so what we want to do is we want to
see the difference between these two
ones because one we have how high
location reading the other one is the
relationship between the two
so let's
get these analysis going quickly
doing a split view
so in this split view
you can see here you can split the maps
by layers so in one we're going to pick
our h3 geom here you can
turn it off we're going to turn off our
gw3 analysis model from here turn it off
and so right now our h3g rooms are here
and then we go to this one again we turn
over h3gu so here's our model there's
our h2 geos
and in split view if you move the map
both maps get moved at the same time and
if you zoom in
and you highlight certain geoms you
actually be able to they both get
highlighted in both of these maps
so as you can see here
they get highlighted and moved over here
as well
so let's focus in on some of these see
how we how this analysis will help us
figure out some get some more insight
from this data set
so let's pick the highest rating on
location
so it would be right there in the red
you can see these were rated very highly
yeah let's focus on that one and we can
see that this one has some relationship
the overall rating has some relationship
with the location
as easy as that so you can compare the
two together like this one and this one
this is very location based why it's
rated so highly
and we use that using our model
and you can keep going around like this
one has not
uh lesser rating
but
the lesser rating but it is partly
location-based why it isn't so on the
opposite side of things maybe location
of this area listings aren't that great
even though they're really close to each
other so that's something to look into
another way that we're able to get more
like extract more analysis from this
so from here let's take it up of even
another level
uh we're going to be enriching this data
set with some of our data sets from the
data catalog so we removed the split
view
we removed our model for now we're just
keeping our h3 geoms for now
and then from here
we're going to go to our data catalog
we go back to our workspace
and then right there we're going to go
to the data observatory which allows us
that has our spatial data catalog and
this catalog has premium data sets
public data sets from all different
providers we provide for transportation
and you can get it immediately
uh in in with your accounts and then
you're able to put them into your map
very easily
uh so for our particular example which
you want to take this data set and put
it into our map uh we're going to look
for something within the united states
because los angeles is the united states
and something that has maybe uh urbanity
or
population density and some tourism so
we're going to pick united states we're
going to use public data so you can
easily access this and then we use cardo
as a provider
and then from here we're going to look
at what we have which right here luckily
we have spatial features for h3
resolution which is exactly what we're
doing h3 and we have an issue data set
here
uh so let's click on it
and when you click on it you get a
preview of the data set and it tells you
what key variables exist within here so
it breaks it down for you so you don't
have to look for all the key data sets
or the specific columns you want and you
click on the data you actually get to
see a preview of the data and how it
looks and where the columns for it these
are the first 10 rows
we see them
and then subscription is as easy as just
clicking this button you just click
subscription you agree to the license
that you're used to this confirm the
subscription
and again keep this in mind we're going
right back to our data explorer because
i want to enunciate that like we really
try to make it as easy as possible and
data explores where all your data is
going to be so if you ever have an idea
data explorer you have a new tab data
observatory and then subscription and
then spatial features are going to be
right there your subscriptions and if
you subscribe to multiple one it will be
right there
so we have our data now in our file you
can access it by clicking the top right
you can actually get the sql to get this
data set so if you use a custom query
you can actually get the data set there
but this data set's actually humongous
it's the whole of the united states with
h3 so we're actually going to create
tile sets for this
so for anyone that doesn't know about
tilesets tilesets it's a instead of just
using a normal table a tile set it
allows you to display at a very high
performance level
uh large data sets and so creating toss
is very easy in cardo you just click
this create
and then you can create a map but the
table is humongous it's the whole united
states you just click above it and you
can create a topic just like that
and so exactly similar to our import
process you can name the data set you
can put this into your connection again
because of our cloud data features you
can if you don't want to work with a
cardo or you want to do some analysis
for it you can just put it into your
cloud data warehouse just to create this
data set we're going to put it in this
project here
and we're going to name it
and then we're going to save it in there
and as i said before for tile sets uh
the reason why they're so efficient
because of zoom levels so what they do
is they display features at a zoom level
base so right here we're setting that
zoom level so anything above this it
won't get displayed
at certain zoom levels and you can also
see the sql query again because this is
what we're doing at our side and if you
really want to you can configure
yourself but again the ui can do that
for you so for this example we're going
to be using the ui just to make it
easier for everyone
clear that
and then let's at the zoom level we're
going to set it so 12 is the maximum of
the two level
and then we're gonna
we're gonna set it to seven
and then from here
we're picking what columns we want to
use for this top set so we have a search
bar we're going to be picking tourism
because this will affect the location
rating of nearby listings we're going to
pick urbanity like where it is maybe
it's a rural high dense area and then
the pot total population within this uh
within this uh the area of the airbnb
but there might be more people there
that might have kept reading so again we
get a preview of where this is going to
get headed and we just click create
and then just like up here you can
continue using cardo while this gets
created into the background as you see
here click the top
like it's that's here and you see that
it's getting worked in the background
so while that gets created actually we
already have a pre-creative aura so we
don't have to wait anymore for this you
can just click on the toss-up and this
looks a little bit different from the
normal data table that we saw before in
the data preview you can see that we
have a sample data set up here and then
we have exactly the zoom levels that
we've set for this specific tile set and
the count of the total amount of
features already in this tile set and
more metadata in case you want to see
like if you created properly or if you
want to just recreate it yourself for a
different one for different purposes so
you can distinguish between them here
so we have our child set in our data set
right so let's actually put it into the
map we're working on right we did all
this way so
let's actually use it so easy again add
source from
and instead of custom query this time
because we already have the data set
available to us we're just going to put
table and toss it go to our connection
we're going to be using for this
and then going into and getting our top
going to the project
right there there's our filezip
and then adding the source
and as quick as that
we can see that we have
we scroll to the bottom we have the new
source from there and we have a new
layer but we can't see our tile sets
right because we mentioned that it's by
zoom level
right so we have to zoom into the area
that we're working with to actually see
the top sets we configured
so you can see the zoom level
by going to the zoom column here we see
where it's in little four level five uh
we'll keep zooming in
and even though we can't see it the
tileset is for the whole of the united
states that's why it's zoomed all the
way up because that's what it's showing
so we keep zooming in
and you can see it got generated here
like tassels are getting generated and
you see the whole top set
as you saw before so at eight we're able
to finally get the tile set to show up
see and right here you can see the tile
sets are getting generated just to make
sure that you know that they're getting
generated in this way
so let's look into this
into this a little bit more
so again more options layer styling oh
wait but yes first we have to rename it
just to make sure that all layers are we
conditioned all our layers
and then let's style this just to get
some understanding of this data set
right because we just imported it so
we're just going to do a color based and
we're going to do population uh urban
data use
and then you can see
in los angeles with the data set like of
course in the core it's very highly
that's area while out here it's very
rare
so
it's similar to um
our normal table we can just quickly
make a map out of this from this data
set alone to give you some idea of
what's going on so for this particular
example we're actually going to turn off
the opacity because we're going to
actually use this information and see
the geoms
from our original airbnb listings to see
maybe if something has a very high
rating
maybe has a high high
density or it has a high population so
we just layered and remember the
tilesets are over
over these geom ids so if we zoom in
and we want to look into that specific
uh geo
we can see that there's a population of
this many people or this this is how
dense it is as you can see there
and
tiles are getting rendered and you can
see here this is how we can get a
specific geoms and get more input and
get more understanding of why maybe
they're that way
as you can see here high density high
density maybe there's a bunch of pois
tourism points around there maybe that
explains why location reading is really
great
and then from here we're going to take
this even a step further besides just
showing it on the map
we're going to be using this data set to
actually
get some widgets it's which is another
way to be able to interact with your
data set so again we have our layer
but we also have our widget section
which right here we're going to make use
our tile set which is on layer d
we click on the layer
and then we have different types of
widgets available for you so we have
formula category histogram timetable and
the table uh time series in the table so
for this one let's do the total
population within our map so we're able
to see how many people actually live
within this area so we're going to put
sum and we're going to use the
population
just click that and you can see there
our widget got formed with this amount
of numbers in it let's rename it so
people know that this is represents the
total population
and then you see that it's a badly
formatted population as you can see
there that's not very user friendly and
that's not how we see population numbers
so we do have a formatting for this
down here
and let's choose
uh
like this one just to get a little more
into the depths of it so it's just a
million
a lot more friendly formatting so you
understand the population of it
and really quickly because
these widgets are interactive actually
with your map so if you move around your
map
to it shows the total population that
exists when the map goes
so if you zoom out it moves to the whole
population that's again the map and you
zoom all the way in to a specific area
it'll regenerate
with the total population that it sees
on the map so it's like if you want to
do some analysis for this that's another
way to do that with widgets so let's
create another object so we go back we
use our tileset data site again
and then we go to the sum again but this
time around let's use pois
uh because we want to see maybe um if
there's a lot of red which are like
better location rating in the geo maybe
it's because of dui maybe there's just
it's a big tourism area and so the
location for people matter a lot so we
put tourism
and you can see here which is a little
red there's 183
uh pys within that area which maybe
that's the relationship between the two
that's why the ratings are really high
so we change the tours and pois and if
you scroll around
and very quick you can see that it got
changed into that
they dynamically change as we scroll
around to this area so you can see in
the blue area there's a lot less people
eyes maybe that's why the people don't
really care about location in this area
so let's go back and then let's get
another widget and this time around uh
we're going to be using a category
widget instead this time so we can click
on category here
and then we're going to be using our um
this time around we're going to focus on
urbanity so maybe
there's a
tall population but maybe there's a
relationship between there's more insect
and gap between not just a hybrid area
but medium area
so if we scroll around again
the map will actively change you can see
that they're broken down into different
categories within the tosa themselves so
like you scroll around
you can see it changes based on what's
available in the map and what dense
areas are there
as you can see there
and then finally our final widget
uh because we've we've been doing a lot
of things about the tile set but we
actually want to see what airbnb
listings are actually on the map
themselves
so
again we name our widgets so people know
that it's annuity levels
and then
we're going to get our loss widget which
is our table widget
right there and instead of the tile set
we're going to be
sorry using that
there we go
we're going to be using our airbnb the
original airbnb distinct to be able to
see what is in there and we're going to
use the table voicer for this
so the table widget actually shows you
the points are showing on the map and
specifically all the columns that we do
and you can take the columns as well so
on the left we don't care about carter
id we don't want to show this to a user
so we care about
score locations uh price numbers uh so
you can config this
uh into here
as you can see here so we care about
review locations and score ratings and
the price number just in case people are
interested in maybe there's a there's a
difference in pricing within these
listings
and also really quickly you can also
change the amount of rows that are shown
when you see the map so you can say like
five or ten uh really quickly
see as you see here
you can change it and then more rows are
here but these are the ones that
immediately are showing up you can do
them by
uh ordering by the price number you just
talk about those columns here
let's rename this
and these are the listings that we're
seeing on the map themselves just
because we don't want to just see the
data that we enrich this dataset with we
also want to see the airbnb listings
we're looking at here
and so we move around
we see these data sets changes at the
same time
so let's finally name our final map
because we've done two
two maps already uh this is our final
map
uh we're gonna show everybody location
uh reading analysis
and then it gets updated and that's the
name of our map
so finally let's actually share this map
with the world right we spent a lot of
time making it and we spent all these
widgets so we want everyone to do it um
and just very quickly also on the side
besides just zoom in and out you can
actually use the lasso tool to actually
like
hone in on some areas so if you click
lots of but you can also uh polygons
rectangles or circles you click laptop
and you see here you can like
you can draw the around the point that
you want
as you see here
we want to focus on this specific area
it'll filter it out right away so
and you'll move all the widgets
accordingly to that
as you can see here
so even if we scroll around it doesn't
matter if we're only focusing on that
you can actually edit the mask as well
too if you're not happy with it you can
just entertain the right way
so and then you can just remove it and
get back to your map as you had it
before
so again back to sharing back to sharing
this map so it's easy as clicking the
share button up there at the top right
and then
you can just leave it as private as
default every map is private uh because
you're working on it but you can put it
to the organization that you're working
in so you you know you have other users
you can share it with them but for this
we're gonna put a public map you have
the copy of the public share that we're
copying here but if we have iphones as
well if you want to put it on the
website
you open a new link
and then we just copy it that url
and this will be available for anyone if
you open it and
there's our map display or widgets are
there and this is what user will see as
easy as that we just shared a map and
created a map for everyone to see
yep
and that's our example
and let me go back to the slides really
quickly
okay
okay and that's that's our that's the
examples does anyone any questions about
any of the things we went over
uh and really quickly if you want to
request a demo or anything uh definitely
uh reach out
uh we we definitely want to learn your
use cases and we'll be able to figure
out what's the best way to do it and
then again we really uh really recommend
creating a free trial account it's free
and you can just try out the platform
and it comes with a cardo data warehouse
ready for you to use so we find it
really helpful and if you want these
slides please reach out to cole and you
go get your email we'll forward that all
to you so you can create this example
whenever you want to and get more a more
understanding of what you need
sounds great
all right thank you so much